i am columbus police chief tom quinlan
today is christmas eve a time when we
should be gathering with those we love
the family of andre hill has nothing to
celebrate this holiday
someone very important won't be with
them this holiday or any other
a columbus police officer is responsible
for that
and that breaks my heart this is why
today
i am announcing action to terminate
officer adam coy
i have filed two departmental charges
alleging critical misconduct
against officer coy after an expedited
investigation
i have sustained those charges
based on these findings i am
recommending discipline of termination
today officer officer coy will be served
notice
of the charges against him and my
recommendations now go to the public
safety director the process of
departmentally charging an officer
typically includes a hearing before the
chief of police
before a determination of wrongdoing or
any discipline
in this case i have bypassed that step
like all of you i witnessed his critical
misconduct firsthand
via his body worn camera i have seen
everything i need to see to reach the
conclusion that officer
coy must be terminated immediately
some may call this a rush to judgment it
is not
we have an officer who violated his oath
to comply
with the rules and policies of the
columbus division of police
and the consequences of that violation
are so great
it requires immediate action
this violation costs an innocent man his
life
there are two administrative
investigations underway
this first investigation is related to
officer coy's unreasonable use of deadly
force
failure to activate his body-worn camera
and failure to render
aid to mr hill